their boy Jadon but the one thing I
think that haunts me the most is one of
my most popular pranks was was whenever
I snuck into the Gatorade HQ and I
deceived the security guards and lied
and said that I was working there excuse
me ladies do you know where floor Pepsi
Co is
on I got to check in okay uh we're with
the Gatorade commercial team we just
have to go talk to Pepsi Co ID yes ma'am
we got to go shoot a commercial for them
so do they know you coming up there yes
ma'am you're not in the system I have to
call upstairs no yeah you're going to
have to call upstairs this was kind of
like last minute just tell them we're
with the commercial team you guys don't
remember uh Jon used to do pranks for
quite a long time on YouTube one of my
more liked prankers I don't like a lot
of them but Jon was the exception
because he did some that I re enjoyed uh
but some of them were kind of wild and
uh you know he recently stopped as he
really rediscovered his faith and
realized that a lot of the stuff that he
was doing according to himself wasn't
okay why can't you follow Christ and
make content I mean you're over here
making millions upon millions of people
happy isn't that of God isn't a Godly
thing to put a smile on people's faces
and to make them happy and while
bringing happiness to the world is of
God you can also bring happiness to the
world through wickedness you can bring
happiness to the World by serving the
devil you know not all happiness is from
God uh he decides to change his whole
Direction Turn towards God and you know
with some self-reflection he thinks back
on some of the many pranks that people
loved and this is one in question and
that I was part of the commercial team
and I got the prank
done hello can help you hello uh we're
here with IMG Academy didn't the lady
said you guys couldn't do it yes ma'am
but I had got the authorization and then
she got us okay hold up
okay how you doing you guys know where
to go yes sir bro guys confidence is key
like hey what's up my man uh we had some
like test flavors you mind trying some
sure oh appreciate you this one is Emer
oh my gosh a lot of flavor I know
finally G stepped up the game me
personally this my personal favorite
IMAP
us he say I love IMAP us got millions of
views off of it some many people giving
me prop uh corporate they're trying to
get us to use like lingo whenever
someone likes the flavor so can you say
I would definitely hit ice spice I would
definitely hit ice spice I would
too did that but what a lot of
you guys don't know is three people lost
their jobs because of me because I lied
and was saying that I work there I got
three security officers fired that had
been working there for years all because
I wanted to play a practical joke all
because I wanted to entertain you guys
and that's
evil that truly is evil and to those
people that I got fired um I wouldn't
say it's evil um I wouldn't say say evil
I think it's very negligent evil is yeah
there's levels to this and evil is
a bit much cuz when I think of evil I
think of you intentionally going out to
harm people I think there's a certain
level of intentness there what I think
of what he did it was just very thoughts
what you want me I don't like pranks I'm
not I'm not here for it wasting people's
time and stuff and now you're wasting
people's livelihood and money I'm not
really here for that never been a fan so
yeah especially with the repercussion of
that uh after that I'm sorry I truly am
okay
good uh for him to be saying sorry
that's one thing doesn't mean that they
have to forgive him or whatever what not
it's good that he does other things and
pranks I'm happy for that but initially
oh my God I would have been pissed I
really would have been pissed I'm happy
he's just doing something else man I'm
happy he's able to self-reflect and be
like you know that's not the best the
best the best thing I should have done
and at least he recognizes it you know
we all make some mistakes yeah good good
for him good for him if he's able to see
that and selfish flag not a lot of
people can nah it was nothing it was
just that prank it was just a yeah yeah
your prank sometimes have consequences
if your prank cost people their
livelihoods and their jobs it's not just
a prank and that's why it's just a prank
is such an annoying thing it's like
people get these folks riled up get them
really upset you know like I've seen
some pranks where the other person
literally thinks they're being attacked
or they might lose their life like oh
it's just a prank just a prank yeah when
you're adrenaline's rushing when you're
having all these kinds of things like
you're putting people in a really
terrible emotional state that's not just
a prank pranks something you did on your
friends your family the pranks that
we're seeing on YouTube is like
everyone's trying to push the envelope
to see how offensive they can be and how
riled up they can get you and how much
you can freak out and how much they can
have you have a panic attack like I said
you don't know what people on the other
end are going through so you're just
pressing these buttons to see what
happens find out you just launched a
nuclear button you had a dude blast
somebody because he thought he was being
ailed by two individuals and then they
wanted to say you don't have a right to
qunk
what's
qun
stop
stop however you feel about that case
whether or not self-defense it's a gray
Zone and that's what you guys are
operating and you guys are risking your
lives and lives of people around you
what if the cops would have showed up
and started blasting that dude what if
that dude missed y'all hit an innocent
person what if you had the strap on you
for self-defense person and you start
firing back and other people get hurt
like the way you guys are escalating
these kinds of situations is
unreasonable the other aspect of this is
like these are young men who are on
these platforms they have all this Fame
and agulation right doing pranks is one
of the quickest ways to shoot up if you
go extreme enough so they're trying to
just get by honestly I say this every
time I'm glad I wasn't a YouTuber in my
young years who knows what I would have
done who knows how I would have used my
influence or whatever it is with women
with money and all these other things so
these young people are coming into the
game and acting like menaces but I
expect that from people in their early
late teens to early 20s I expect it I
don't think it makes it okay but it's
understandable seeing that growth I
think that's a beautiful thing and so
I'm happy for the brother look at my
content every video where it was someone
getting angry or someone getting in my
face those are my most view videos
because
because when you provoke people and when
you get people out of their element when
you get people in a spirit of Rage it
gets views and I would profit off of
that and I was teaching younger kids
that were looking up to me this is how
you blow up this is how you get big by
provoking people by making people just
trying to do their day or work their job
by getting them angry because you're
doing where you're not supposed to and
so to everybody that ever provoked in my
videos to everybody that I embarrassed
and humiliated in front of millions of
people I'm truly sorry his apology you
know I think it's good to talk about it
with the internet but at the end of day
it's to the people who lost their jobs
to the people who were affected by the
pranks right what everyone saw was this
amazing prank but on the back end of it
is it is people losing their jobs oh I
the security should have been better
listen security lapses happen people
don't get fired over them
instantaneously the reason why they got
fired for this is because this was
highly publicized Jadon made so much
money off this as did his company Prime
they profited off the fact that these
guys and magnified their mistake the
company had to take action so yes
absolutely cost them their job it cost
them their job and in this economy where
people are struggling to make ends meet
sometimes that job is the one thing you
need to just be able to make rent at the
end of the month and you take that from
somebody you might be pushing people
towards homelessness you don't know what
people's living situations like you
don't know if they got kids if they got
bills H behind you don't know the amount
of people who are living paycheck to
paycheck in America I don't remember the
number was you remember the number was
no but it's a lot
73% of Millennials are living paycheck
to
paycheck when you CAU somebody's job in
that kind of situation what are you
expecting people oh you guys are just
being oldheads all this other stuff how
many of these pranks have you seen gone
South where someone's had enough like
the one in the grocery store where the
people got arrested for
no y'all think this is just a prank it's
not it's real life you're taking
people's grocery excuse me this is my
stuff say it one more time this is my
stuff what do you mean I buy this no
wait what's going on I scan it you're
taking that from me what what what
excuse me yo what's up wait what
happened I buy those stuff those
groceries those are mine you Hing me you
see the the water bottle
hey get
off how's it going man disappear from me
okay
bro homie tried to fight me over his
paper towels that's actually comedy but
uh me personally like if someone's
trying to take my groceries I'm probably
giving the same reaction I feel like
everybody is not going to let anyone
take their groceries whatever bro that
was that was
hilarious n n get shot need to learn n
bro get shot I know you said you don't
wish it on I wish it on them I wish it
on them do you see me right now shutting
the sorry I ain't said I just
I need I ain't said
the I said I said cook him and you're
cooking me I'm just saying it it annoys
me because we've been saying this dumb
going to happen we've been saying
that we've been saying that and then
it's becoming more popular and listen I
love Jon that's the homie but like I
think because of how he does his stuff
so people are trying to emulate some
people do it poorly but that's been
happening some people do it poorly uh we
also have a Discord that's really
popping in a Reddit where we get a lot
of our topics so if you want to submit
go check that out also our Instagram's
not too bad go check out all our socials
okay hi you're traumatizing people and
you're publicizing them on their
internet without their consent for your
own personal gain it is incredibly
unethical it is incredibly unethical and
you guys think it's funny but when it's
your own family member that's freaking
out is being mocked online and laughed
at because somebody stole their
groceries or something stupid
you won't probably have that same kind
of mindset because it's For Your
Entertainment you think it's all hunky
dory it's amazing but when it's your
people when it's you yourself you don't
think it's funny anymore that's how I
feel about this you know people ask me
too sometimes like oh aren't you a
comedian don't you make jokes yeah yeah
yeah attending is completely different
when between a prank and when you do
comedy when you do prank they do not
know what's going on the context is
different you might think the context is
the same because you're at the end of
the day you're going to say it's a joke
or it's a prank and you're making joke
therefore is the same thing it is not
when you pay a ticket to go to a show
this is the understanding that I pay to
participate in this experience boom even
if when you're posting videos online you
are publicizing yourself to the world
you're putting yourself out there for
comments from your comment section from
other careers that's what you're doing
right you don't want to review don't
open a business that's it I would never
go out into the street film people who
are just going about their day and start
roasting people or saying a bunch of
crazy that's what these people are
essentially doing much worse but you
guys get the analogy it's not the same
thing it's not even close a prank from
outside from someone that does not no
that's just living their life and what
we're doing and what we're doing this is
not even the same thing no so the only
thing that you understand is it's a joke
but it's not but yes at the end of the
day like I said I support the fact that
people can change people can grow people
can learn from their ways and they can
do things and I even think there's ways
to do pranks ethically but you have to
be consider of the people that you're
pranking and the issue with all of these
people is that they don't give a they're
trying to make content first and that
they don't think about anything else
afterwards so whether it was Kai going
into the store and stealing things from
the tip charar or what my brother Jon
was doing at the time like these are not
considerate of the people that they're
actually pranking that's not a prank
that's just malicious you know when you
pranking your friends you know them you
know what they can handle so I would
hope that you take that into
consideration how you prank them and
even that can go s like if I know my
friend can't swim I'm not just going to
throw him into a pool and then just
laugh at him and record it the whole
time if he's truly terrified cuz he
might not find that funny and there's
going to be a whole issue afterwards
that's between friends y'all playing
with people's lives and they're
strangers I'll never understand that so
again I'm hoping this prank genre dies
out there's still a couple people left
who are menaces to society and I hope a
lot of them start disappearing more and
more over time but uh yeah if you guys
want to see what decent price look like
just go look at just for gags I think
they do it the best out of everybody
I've seen so far and they ask they put
release forms they say would you be part
of this and if they say no they never
publicize it do you think any of these
guys are doing that nah a lot of my
content wasn't quote unquote that bad
I'm G just get rid of all of it it's all
gone I'll never be seen again because I
love you guys and to answer the question
why did Jon delete all his videos I
deleted it because of you that's why I
deleted it I love you guys that
much even though I haven't met all of
you guys even though I don't know all
you guys I love you that much that's the
reason why I deleted all my content at
any rate I don't want to say too much on
the prank topic I just um I know it's
stop I stopped by this video and it's
like it's cool to see people have growth
cuz even me looking back at some of the
stuff I've done in the past there's some
things I'm not proud of that I've had to
apologize to people over and I'm proud
of that because I don't want to live
with that regret on my heart it's also a
burden off you that's lifted when you're
able to make those amends so I'm happy
that maybe your soul feels a little bit
lifted from this and uh yeah if you guys
ever have things that you guys need to
apologize for to repent for to change
for I hope you guys go through that
process as well apologies are not bad it
is not a bad thing to say you're sorry
it's not a bad thing to be wrong it's
not a bad thing to to to be convinced
100% you have things right and then
learn afterwards like oh I was reallying
wrong and I hurt people it's okay and
it's scary to admit that because it
means you have to confront yourself and
you have to confront the people that you
hurt and they may not forgive you but I
think going through that process helps
you sleep better and helps you be a
better person in general so I'm
supportive of anybody who does that and
I'm very happy for the brother whatever
pth he takes in life going forward I'll
always uh I always
support good on you anything else you
want to say no you better give all three
of those people a
job can he do that now I don't
know no I mean listen those people might
never forgive I don't that then that's
if you made a fool of me online and cost
my job right I'm going be salty that's
their right they they have the right to
not
yeah
I let us know what you guys think in the
comments so I've already started up ABA
preaching the floor which is where most
of our funny videos are going to be I've
should just be called Floyd Floyd sure
cuz you know I need it to be a specific
brand Floyd might be too General there
might be a bunch get mad at that yeah
yeah AB a preach to the floor okay go
check it out I'm going to be dropping
five videos on February 1st so if you're
watching this after then it's already
out